we welcome back here on the show it was
great when he was here in person a few
um i think it was about a year ago and
now he is in another
red hot show lovecraft country airs
sundays at 9 00 pm eastern
on hbo it premiered a couple of weeks
ago so many people
are talking about it and part of it is
because of how well-acted it is
that includes courtney b vance back here
on the show how are you sir
um very well what a wonderful segue that
was very nice rich you've done this show
before
you know what uh this is what i uh this
is this is the only way i know how to
roll i only know one speed
i only know one speed that's it i like
your speed
well i appreciate yours as well i i want
to give you the floor on the show
because how would you describe it to
people who have yet to see it
what would you say about it
it's a family that during the 50s where
black folks could not travel freely
throughout the country especially north
to south south to north so
there was a group of people who traveled
the
country uh um and they scoped out places
for
people to do black folks to do daily
your daily stuff get your hair cut get a
good meal get a nice place to stay
women get your hair did you know toes
done nails all that kind of stuff
and so and once they and all those
things were compiled in a book called
the green book and so
our family does that and on the way uh
down there we know what we're going into
emmett till didn't take it seriously
when he went from chicago down
to mississippi and he paid the ultimate
price but we
we know we knew we were getting into um
and so
uh we go down there we know the the
physical monsters that we'll
encounter which are the sheriffs and the
the policemen and the the you know folks
just folks racist folks in general but
uh there
are actually um
figurative monsters down there and we
actually
are battling uh myself jonathan majors
plays my nephew and journey smallmet who
plays uh
his good good friend with the three of
us as we're traveling we discover we're
in the middle of some
some really we're battling both the
figurative and the metaphysical monsters
and it's uh it's quite
quite thrilling and exciting when you
say metaphysical monsters you're
again that's the part about this show
that um
you know uh is jarring when it first
appears you're talking about actual
monsters that's what you're referring to
yes yeah people you just don't know what
you're you're
and that's the beauty of of any show is
that you think you know what's going on
and and you kind of do know what's going
on maybe if you watch the show and you
get love
you'll be lulled into a sense of oh we
know this show we we
we kind of we we're we're in rhythm with
the show and then all of a sudden
bam the show takes you in a different
direction and that's what great
these great limited series needs serious
do they
they throw you you think until you're on
the edge of your seat something's gonna
happen i know sometimes
someone's going no it didn't happen but
i know someone's gonna have an episode
so you you know you really you know when
they're done
well this particular genre and it's an
action flick and
you know it's a horror flick so it's
it's you know they're incredibly hard to
do and
misha green and her her team and the
cast and crew
and the producers jordan peele and
and jv abrams and hbo they they
really it was a struggle to find our
rhythm but we found it and boy did it
pay off well when you
find out uh that you get a uh a
production team a producer team of of
who you just mentioned
and then you see a cast uh you're you're
absolutely i'm sure
for somebody in your profession you're
like okay where do i sign that said when
you get a script like this
did you have to read it a couple of
times to kind of grasp
what i want i'm a huge misha green fan
of the underground and so i wanted to be
in that show
and this came up to me misha i sat down
with her and i knew as soon as i talked
i wanted to do this so it wasn't a hard
sell for me i just i just wanted to be
in it i wanted to be
a part of something that she was doing
because i know her vision is very large
and so this one i mean i i didn't really
know
the extent of of what i mean you talk
about they're gonna be monsters courtney
and
i'm not a real big horrific guy i'm an
action flick guy
so uh i i just went in on faith that
i i knew that uh you know she when she
says it's going to be done it's going to
be done well
and it was hbo and jordan peele and jj
abrams that's what i mean
courtney b vance here on the rich eisen
show when you say action film give me an
action film which one give me give me a
good one
when you're like okay i want to watch an
action what the
the the um what was the one that uh with
the blue
face people and um uh that james cameron
did that
we're all waiting for number two avatar
um avatar that's that's
classic that you know um um
sure with the warmth harrison ford uh
which is pretty much any family by the
way you just you just named every
harrison ford film pretty much outside
of star wars that's
that's i'm i'm a huge harrison ford any
of the
uh the indiana jones series uh
you know um so you know the game of
thrones you know there's an
action by the way you know i mean to be
on an hbo show too
courtney you know um and and michael k
williams
uh part of the michael jordan oh your
um cat you know cast member i love
no doubt i mean michael k williams for
fans who who
of hbo shows might know he was played
chalky white and baudwalk empire but of
course
omar omar from the wire which is one of
the
omar is one of the greatest characters
in tv history you could say
you could really make a case for that
for sure um
so courtney vance here on the rich eisen
show
um you're from detroit does that make
you a lions fan
i don't know if we had this conversation
before but uh have you
probably did but i they i and i think i
i let you know before they just took too
long for me i had to move on
i'm sorry yes i'm sorry it's just that
you know they have never won anything
and i
i wish i could hang with them um but i i
left a long time ago i love my city
but i'm sorry i'm sorry lion i'm sorry
no i know
and you you have a couple of ivy league
schools on your on your
um on your diplomas on your wall so
do you have is there is there a sports
team of yours that you
kind of uh dig that you've followed used
to
anything that uh well i was a patriot
strand for the longest time but that you
know i was
mr mr brady was uh was my guy
um but uh he's moved
so i think i have i have to go down to
tampa bay okay
and that's where the super bowl is this
year so i'm i'm down there
the clippers are my team in basketball
um
yankees on my team in baseball um
i think i've created enough enemies
already i think do i need to stop that
no
i'm a yankee fan and tj jefferson on my
social media grand maester to use the
phrase from game of thrones is a big
time
uh clipper fan who loves the mets and i
tried to get him off the mets and go to
the yankees earlier today just
on this very program about two hours you
know yeah
you're not gonna do that that's like the
socks and the you know
the cubs the cubs sure yeah oh i gotcha
i'm for sure do you have any thoughts on
what the uh on the nba deciding to
to um stop playing for a few days
they had to do something somebody had to
say something and they
they they they made a statement uh uh
the the goat the greatest of all time
got in there with the owners and they
let them know just let the guys talk let
them talk to you gotta let them
you gotta let them talk and you guys
gotta listen um
um because this is bigger than the the
game the
life is bigger than the game and so um
they came to a decision that they made a
statement and then they were going to
get back to playing
but it is it is a i was encouraged that
it was
it was across the board it was baseball
tennis golf
you know um soccer everyone is making us
taking a stand and saying that's enough
um that's enough
and so it is whether or not they they
through the whole season
i think they made a uh the compromise
when they all got together and talked it
through that it was
enough was enough we had to make a
statement we had to say something we
just couldn't keep playing
and not say something which is what you
know
usually a president instead stands up
and comments on something
says something to bring the country
together but we're going to get through
this together
we're going to find out what happened
and just be calm nobody
nothing nothing and so that's why we're
where we are now there's nothing in the
center nobody is
speaking calm who is uh
as a moral authority because there is
none right now and uh
in the white house there is no moral
turn courtney b vance here on the rich
eisen show
the uh emmy award-winning actor from the
american crime story show
people versus o.j simpson from a couple
years ago that was so
remarkable and amazing and you playing
johnny cochran in it
amazing did you learn anything about
like how did you prepare for that
character of we as we all know
i'm getting rich i jumped in and because
uh you know
i didn't want to feel that i was in my
head imitating him so i
i read uh jeffrey tubman's book uh
and then i jumped in read it a couple of
times and i jumped in and i
got a kernel that was all i needed and i
knew that the scripts were great that
were the
ten scripts that were written for our
episodes and i i
thought that what i didn't get the
audience would
forgive me yet because the scripture was
so good so
that that worked for me this time so
sometimes you know you got to do your
research and and hang with the genius of
wreath that we're doing
uh on maggio um playing ceo franklin
right aretha franklin's father reverend
theo franklin
that when i had to do uh the research
had to jump in and
do the research and do you know spend
some time and
try to get his rhythms down because i'm
preaching and singing
so it was a much more involved uh
process but
um it uh um that the anthony hemingway
uh uh was with us for um for the ojp and
he's with us
uh on the genius aretha he's uh he's my
guy i'm very
proud to be a part of uh this together
with him as we're we're gonna try to get
back to we didn't finish shooting it so
we're going to try to get back sometime
next month or the month after and bring
it home
um and then that's yeah it's awesome the
last one for you here
i'm going to jump way back how old did
sean connery turn
90 this week is that a true story that's
true 90 years old you have it's 1990
the famed hunt for red october i don't
know if you were in
many scenes with with him but you got
any good connery stories from the set
yes absolutely we were he had just had
throat surgery
and so you know back in that day there
was all this atmospheric smoke
it was terrible for you i don't know
anybody survived it but
they would when he was when he wasn't on
the set
it was they they smoked it up we could
barely see each other with so much smoke
on that
said but when he was on the set we just
heard someone just scream out
sean's on the way and uh because he had
let everybody know
early on he said you got me you got me
for a month
and there's no smoke i want no smoke
so uh he got uh he got under that
everyone
everyone had a fan and everyone was
waving their you know their scripts and
whatever just to clear
the air but before he got on the set
because he would walk away if they would
if there was any smoke in there so that
was all very very
very classic classic sean connery
telling everybody that you don't you
only got me for a month
and when i'm here there's no smoke
that that had to be uh you know you were
i think we discussed this maybe the last
time you were on but uh i'm i
kind of have a new audience right now
anyway you must that must have been one
of your first
gigs obviously you were in hamburger
hill before that which is a remarkable
film
but yeah that had to be right
first big you want to talk about action
movies i mean my gosh
um that had to be pretty big for you to
be on a a set like that and here comes
sean connery smoke or not you know
that had to be right huge for you that
had to be big
that was big it was it was big it was
very difficult to get into because i
i've read the book several
times and i was stuck i'm one of them so
bad and
but i was doing a play at the public
with joe papp
and i my agent at the time it
let the general manager of the public
know that if the role comes up
you know he should be allowed to go and
the general manager yep no problem he'll
be
but of course he never because the
general manager never told that to joe
and so
of course he came up i got the role and
and the agent calls the general manager
says he's got the role he's got to go
and the general manager no
because i had replaced joe morton in
this play
so they he the gentleman didn't want to
let me go so i had to
i had to go up and talk to joe and he
told me why i couldn't go
and i'm saying i just knew my spirit i'm
out so i
by the time i got back downstairs to get
ready to do the show
they told me that uh i guess uh uh sam
cohen at iceham
um at the time uh got arrested so to
call joe up in the general manager and
uh
the the sam pointed you got to let him
go joe did
jenny and joe told the defenders
gentleman did you tell him he could go
up
this movie came up for him the general
manager had to admit he did
and there we go and off you went and now
uh lovecraft country the latest uh on
your remarkable filmography and
uh in all the tv shows that you have
been doing courtney b vance
uh on twitter and instagram courtney b
vance thank you for joining again always
appreciate our
chats yes sir a pleasure always a
pleasure you're very
you're smooth smooth i will
i will take all three of those smooths
thank you so much
much appreciated best to you and your
family we'll chat again soon hopefully
yes sir thank you you bet right back at
you courtney b vance lovecraft country
on hbo
sundays 9 eastern